White House senior adviser Jared Kirsten
will testify this morning about his
contact with Russian officials and
businessmen the Senate Intelligence
Committee is expected to question the
president's son-in-law about why he
initially failed to disclose the
meetings in a statement released this
morning kosher denies that the Trump
campaign colluded with Russia Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill with a preview
of Kushner's testimony Nancy good
morning good morning well Kushner knows
that he is a key focus of the Russia
investigation and he has released 11
pages of testimony aimed at showing that
he has nothing to hide in it he says
that any meetings that he had with
Russian dignitaries were brief and
routine and he goes into quite a bit of
detail about that a now infamous meeting
that he attended with Don Jr and a
Russian lawyer in June of 2016 Kushner
says he didn't read through the entire
entire email chain beforehand and so he
didn't know that Trump jr. had said that
he was open to getting Russian dirt on
Hillary Clinton Kushner says he got to
the meeting late they were talking about
adoptions and that he felt that the
meeting was so pointless that he
actually emailed his assistant asking
her can you please call me on my cell I
need an excuse to get out of this
meeting Kushner also disputes reports
that he tried to set up a secret back
channel with Russia in a meeting with
then ambassador Sergey kis lyac before
his father-in-law was inaugurated
Kushner says he did ask about using the
Russian embassy to communicate but only
to discuss Syria during the transition
after he is grilled in the Senate
Intelligence Committee today Jeff
Kushner is expected to go before the
House Intelligence Committee go through
this same ordeal tomorrow it's acordes
thank you very much